[Music]
yes captain
[Music]
yes captain the beginning playback now
[Music]
Peter you saw an obsidian game I did you
did the one T's last night right so
let's hit some questions
it looks like fallout how could similar
to fallout is it considering obsidian
its history with New Vegas and the
creators of the original fallout going
back are working on this so how much
does it like fallout I think the only
piece of the equation that really isn't
there is well maybe a couple it's not
set on earth there's no mention of like
nuclear war or anything like that but in
most respects the moment-to-moment
gameplay this sort of systems at work
the way dialogue trees function the way
characters look at you they're talking
in dialogue wait combat looks like yeah
that all feels a lot like fallout I
think most people are gonna play this
game and think like they're playing
phone just doesn't have the name in the
title but it really is fallout and so
many other respects but set on what
numerous planets numerous planets in a
distant solar system
this is the spot or Stimac security
like Fallout games like a lot of
obsidian games it's about sort of the
choices you make and you know you have
freedom to make a choice and follow one
path or I don't say just another but
multiple paths right so normally you
would need some sort of like license or
key to dock somewhere like land on a
planet and dock at a certain point but
we were told there's ways around that
but it's hidden didn't get into too many
details like there so there it's not
like a no man sky
laying on a planet discover no you are
landing at a space station or an outpost
yeah but you're also not piloting your
ship manually okay so it's late so you
are telling it where to go from Mass
Effect just warp around planets so Tim
Kaine and Leonard Boyarsky Leonard
Boyarsky famed for falling working on to
fall out fall up to do it to black aisle
doesn't watch other people who worked
with them on the original Fallout games
we're back in this project
this might seem very obvious but for
those who don't know this is gonna feel
feel more like New Vegas than Fallout 3
for instance or fallout 76 New Vegas
like you said is very much about the RPG
kind of choices you you make along the
way as well as that Bethesda like
exploration it's just like pure sci-fi
is it more like I don't know
aesthetically from the b-roll we have
I'm curious what what they're going for
because obviously like fallouts that
frozen 50s Americana
in a post-apocalyptic world but you said
this is more I don't know this just
sounds like what we're kind of expecting
from starfield well no so I think it
kind of does borrow from that like
mid-century sense of like marketing and
design and what you see because the
story is very important like when I say
you know how things are like the direct
products and stuff in the game
everything is tied to one of many
corporations that exist in the universe
the aura in the solar system
you know the colonies exist because of
corporate desires and ambitions the
bullets you use the armor you wear the
way conversations go between people
corporations kind of play into all of
that it almost sounds like Borderlands
in that respect right yeah and there is
an amount of humor to the game as well
because like you'll see you know this
idea of the corporation being so
important to someone because they were
warrant under that banner yeah right
that like the example they gave is like
oh there's a guard who's injured and you
can go up to him and I'm sure you can
kill him and steal his stuff or you can
try to heal him but you don't have the
bandages from the corporation that he is
according to them he'll be like oh those
band-aids those aren't good enough like
I I mean no thanks like I'll wait until
someone comes along with auntie Mames
brand or whatever if they said like who
you're playing outside of the fact that
like the premises like corporation
corporate colonies kind of like have
they mention who your protagonist is
somewhere you're creating so you are a
voiceless you know character you you do
create the character from scratch this
is a first-person only game while you're
playing life you can let the camera idle
and it'll go to a third-person camera
rotate around you but you essentially
are a someone who was you know
incubating for long-term space travel I
think you're supposed to go for ten
years and a scientist wakes you up after
seven years because he's sort of like
got this plan to get some materials to
help fix or change the way that people
are forced to hibernate a lot of those
details are still kind of up in the air
but there was definitely a scientist who
looked like a mix of Doc Brown and Rick
you know kind of like waking you up out
of your chamber all right I'm getting
you out early I need you to go like down
in this planet and do some stuff but the
thing is is that you don't have to do
that if you don't want to you can you
can literally go the opposite direction
and and turn on that guy you don't have
to you don't have to do your you know
even though he resurrected you and
that's how you begin the game
it's beginning of your games and it's
not like his story necessary so so
what's the other component to it right
like there's fallout they're scavenging
yeah but so I want to go back into the
like the fallout stuff it makes it so
fun because it gets really deep remember
I was mentioning like combat kind of
looking like fallout you know how and
followed sometimes when your companions
kill someone it'll do that slow motion
third-person look at them yeah have that
like deadpan look on their face
exact same thing you're gonna see here
you know how your perks are based on the
special system and then fallout there's
a brand new acronym in this game what is
it they wouldn't say that for some
reason they're too sweet the keys in a
cure that's another six letter acronym
like they they are literally working you
know and even then like when we saw the
T's for this like we got a little thing
with a spaceship it was like the new her
was like I figure do a saying but it's
like I almost wonder are they making an
extension will fall out we're like yeah
earth became too irradiated and couldn't
do anything anymore so people just left
and of course capitalism took over yeah
you know like yeah there's another
special thing is that gonna be like you
have it fallout perhaps I don't think
I'm doing any of that but there's
certainly well aware of fallout speaking
of Tim Kaine one of the co-creators of
this he is like I do a post-mortem on
every Fallout game whether I make it or
not I'm keenly aware of what that series
is doing specifically because it's
something that they founded on their
ideals
you know they broke free not really
broke free from interplay but they kind
of defined their own thing and that's
what they want to keep doing and they've
been informed about what fall it's done
and what they like about what they don't
it seems like they're kind of borrowing
here and there to a degree
I don't had enough of this [ __ ]
I'm just the [ __ ] tarmac guard no one
said nothing about fighting no raps
[Music]
distress call from here [ __ ]
they told me that weren't allowed got me
I just do what I'm told I was told not
to do such so going back to like
scavenging or what is the replacement to
that like if is it just you're confined
to a space station are you exiting are
you exploring a planet or the worlds it
is a planet yeah so I mean to be totally
transparent everyone watching this we're
doing this before the game Awards right
yeah there will be some of the stuff
shown at the Game Awards you guys don't
have that context like the audience
might but for anyone who hasn't seen
that stuff you know it is the one planet
we saw was a mix of sort of like urban
ish not like skyscrapers right but like
urban areas in wilderness where the
wilderness is kind of like part and
parcel of the environment it's not
really like segmented off there are
multiple planets they wouldn't tell me
how many and yeah there are essentially
little open worlds and you have a lot of
stuff you can do you can explore you can
find sub quests and you can follow your
main objective if you wish your
companions also play a pretty big part
in all of this there you can get to a
point where they will leave you they
don't respect to you oh if you're making
certain choices yeah if you clash with
their ideals at one point they can just
say like you know it's been real but I
don't like like that it and I like being
able to probably kill that person
they're walking away that's not like
fallout 4 or what they at least one for
yeah a little bit yeah so the Companions
the way that works they showed like a
screen where there's like five or six
characters you can only ever take two
with you at a time they are introducing
a new like Party member type which is
the leader so the leader can sort of
benefit from the strengths of the the
other people in the party so you can be
a leader in customized characters and
they'll sort of feed into your strengths
you can make someone else the leader on
your team and you can be a following
to them it's pretty interesting and you
know when it comes to customization the
the perk system I was mentioning before
there is a flip side to that which is
the flaw system and I think this is one
of the most interesting things that I
saw in the game so far you know the way
it was described to me in terms of like
the impetus was so many games like give
you the illusion of choice or the
illusion of a world reacting to you and
usually boils down to scripted things
that you know instead of one of a
handful of options but the way this game
works is it will really track everything
that's happening to you so let's say I
get set on fire you know five times in a
few hours or something he will pop up a
screen and say hey so your character we
could give it we could give that
character fear of fire which means
anytime they're near fire they're gonna
take a debuff two-degree but in exchange
for that debuff maybe we'll give you
another perk slot so you can actually
tailor the difficulty around the way
that you manage character flaws which is
super interesting it sounds like you are
the orc in that Nemesis system almost
yeah kind of it's it's certainly like
something that I don't grasp every facet
of because at some point and they were
saying you also can't get rid of flaws
so you could potentially back yourself
into a corner don't I know it
yeah but it's a really fascinating way
of sort of balancing out things and
letting you tailor the difficulty I
guess you're not in total control reg is
even know how that stuff's gonna
manifest but I was like how many flaws
are there and they're like I mean we
came up with more than we could put in
the game and there are a lot you know
when some of the ones they describe is
like fear of Legends or fear of the dark
or fear of a specific type of enemy a
lot of it comes down to fears I don't
know like how that's gonna change
outside of that again just to kind of go
back too far like I keep remembering
things that's doesn't exist
yeah there's no such thing as like vats
necessarily but your character due to
the serum that the doctor gave you I'm
pretty sure that's the cause I give you
like this time dilation ability which is
effectively bullet time but what it
serves in the in combat is it allows you
to break free from twitch gunplay or
twitch melee combat to this more
methodical kind of thing
you're not gonna get like a percentage
of damage per limb that you aim at you
can't like cycle through it it's closer
to bullet time than it is vats or like
more recently Deadeye
when you say no because did I I think
there are systems that allow you to auto
target right as you like strafe you're
used to required to like pinpoint and
designate but yeah but you're doing that
here you're literally just you're
putting a reticle and firing in bullet
time okay but I guess I'm saying is like
in practice what vats offered to
fallouts combat system this does the
same thing it's just more like bullet
time than something as rigid as vats
[Music]
[Music]
for comfort
[Music]
yeah what else about like combat in
general like it doesn't look that
interesting the enemies they showed were
kind of they weren't big and fast and
doing crazy things they were kind of
just there and there was a lot of like
you know front to front melee
confrontations with enemies
we only saw a few types and most of them
were wildlife we saw like some turrets
and stuff like that and that's not
terribly surprising I think the emphasis
is really being put on how you compose
your party because your two companions
obviously act through AI and so it
really it's about how you prepare them
and potentially how you prepare yourself
if you're playing the leader through
them I didn't get a chance actually play
the game that's kind of like the the big
hang-up here I sat through a 45-minute
presentation and did an interview with
Tim and Leonard so I don't know maybe
it'll be more engaging in practice at
first it didn't seem that exciting would
you agree that this is probably the best
time possible to announce a game like
this considering that a lot of people
feel burned by fallout 76 I'd say it's
pretty good I'd say you know another
piece of that in terms of like bringing
a fallout like experience into the
future you know the Fez distill working
with their engine that is not always
that great and for the longest time
obsidian was using other people's
engines even when plunk Bethesda to work
on the games that they were creating
this is being made in Unreal Engine 4 it
looks really smooth I didn't notice any
real glitches apart from like one small
animation glitch that was like
negligible over 45 minutes of live
gameplay in front of me you guys want I
can show you the game yes I've literally
got a bunch of your old people at home
may have seen some of this already will
hop around and I'll show you what we're
doing so this is your spaceship and I
don't know why you have a gun drawn in
your own spaceship and so really the
most you can do here is interact with
your party well your entire party you're
not just the companions that you would
take with you on a mission and each have
their own rooms
you know a lot of the way this game
looks isn't necessarily that inventive
or new it's kind of the same as combat
like combat felt a little dry
just looking at it right so this is
she's AI on the ship she will also sort
of evolve as you play and she will
become a character into herself I didn't
actually get to see too much of her this
is more than I was shown during the demo
but I'm gonna hop around just some of
this dialogue oh I'm judging alright she
looking at you yeah sorry
looking at me or through alright so this
kind of cuts forward I believe I don't
think there was a landing sequence there
no more colorful than I was imagining
yeah it's you know it's it's not like
there on earth and it's post-apocalypse
I mean this is a thriving planet that
they have kind of landed on and you can
kind of see up here like where you get
to see buildings and like trees and
stuff it's not exactly like you're
distracting but yeah so essentially
there was a distress call on this planet
and everyone shows up and you're like oh
what's going on and it's sort of like oh
nature is fighting back right so so what
is your role then like your basic role
is just to investigate like your mother
scenario or something your mercenaries I
would you know what I think I need a
little more context on that like this
sort of premise as it was given to us
was you're at you know you're you're
given this mission by a scientist who
wakes you up early you kind of come to I
mean this is far into the game right
like I've got companions and stuff so I
don't really have a whole lot of context
for Who I am at this point unfortunately
here they're using a lock-picking skill
it seems I took a while it did take a
while you know just kind of you know
scavenging picking up some stuff we
didn't hear too much about crafting
unfortunately it's okay it's yeah it
definitely seems like the Bethesda kind
of conversations yeah they told me that
weren't allowed no it's really
interesting to see it go back I mean at
4-4 right where you're you're in your
character your character is present in a
cinematic now you're going right back
into like looking at some of the eyes
you know what I mean that's like it's
kind of surreal to see that it's also
nice to see that you have the full
dialogue that you're gonna say there I
like Fallout 4 which was like alright it
was like a general idea of where you
were going whether always are in line
with what you wanted to say right so you
can like you know play dumb you can lie
you can do you know different sorts of
things it looked like at some point when
they were playing
there was like a counter and the number
of times that you lied so I think you
can actually become like a worst person
by doing it
let's hop her a little bit more so
here's a kind of look at Kombat it looks
a little bit like destiny and you could
agree but the enemies aren't necessarily
is interesting but these are obviously
real basic oh my god I've got a hammer
yeah so there's a mix of melee and
projectile weapons you have a weapon
wheel that you can pull up I think it's
gonna happen in a few seconds yeah even
like the stiff weird awkward attacks
which you kind of just forgive Fallout
games for after a while or Skyrim even
that looks like that okay so here is one
of the flaws so because we were attacked
enough by this rate of like dinosaurs
central afraid of these Pacific so you
get an extra perk point but obviously
these things happen so whenever you're
near those monsters that'll that'll
occur and that'll be permanent but the
perk point you can spend on a variety of
things
I believe it falls into those categories
acronym like a special like system okay
so is that just some is that just
completely random or is that like does
that persist the more of these rafted
ons you fight the more you're gonna be
scared of them no so I think you know
when you take that flaw it is probably
like a fixed rate of that debuff it's
really just you know I'm not sure that's
exactly what you're asking but like you
know these things will be offered to you
based on things that happen in front of
you and I'm pretty sure they're static
once you accepted them as a for you just
getting you just can't get rid of them
so you know while we're looking at this
it's oh is this your tub it's time yes
it's bullets not right but it really
does kind of serve the same purpose as
something like that's given given
everything around the game that's
happening as well poor little guy
I got [ __ ] flareon
I'm trying to find one of those slow-mo
moments of combat where it cuts to a
companion doing the kill shot
so there's your weapon wheel so now you
got like a scythe that's what dripping
dripping stuff yeah was there
dismemberment I feel like I was earlier
uh I don't recall any there could have
been yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna find this
kill cam shot it's important to me yes
this b-roll is definitely coming around
a kind of armors neck you are like a
corporate board right so yeah I mean you
know there's a there's a game here
that's like very recognizable in a lot
of ways and it would almost in most
cases be like well why don't we want
more the same but I think this is like
an example of sitting getting to make a
game that they want embracing the ideals
of a company that worked with them in
the past and almost gave them like a new
feather in their cap you know with new
Vegas and so it's really interesting to
see them kind of come back to that and I
don't know almost I don't well who knows
how good this game is gonna be right but
as you were saying there's any better
time for a fallout like game that's
doing something new and impressive now
is the time and if I was Bethesda and I
saw this I would I don't know I'm
feeling nervous well so I feel like
every time I pictured starfield in my
head that's what I was seeing really
like I know the fallout comparisons are
obviously there especially from seeing
that footage but the idea of just this
Bethesda like explorable sandbox in a
much more futuristic setting that's just
that seems like what star field would be
to me the fact that it's obsidian doing
it who is historically very good at
writing and good at that RPG RPG kind of
choice driven branching storylines
that's even more encouraging slate
everything I'm seeing from this despite
like some hearts seeming kind of vanilla
for a date it seems like the parts that
I would forgive for being a bit outdated
nothing you don't think on who knows
obviously but it's important to note
correct me if I'm wrong this is the last
this is published by 2k obviously this
is not like the Microsoft to take to
private division and they're sort of
like India Sh label yeah so any game to
come after this will be under Microsoft
because of that acquisition that was
announced as far as I'm aware and when I
was walking around their studio they did
say that they are working on another
project they were I think pulling the
lead programmer off of this to go work
on their new project presumably that
will be in Microsoft Jim but in talking
to Tim and Leonard you know how is that
change going has it done anything to the
company at the moment like you know
yadda yadda yadda you said there's still
a pile of paperwork we're still signing
stuff it's not clear so it's interesting
to see obsidian at this point with a
game like this while they're also
transitioning to being owned after 15
years of independence it'll be really
interesting to see what happens at this
game and what happens with the future of
obsidian how far into a development is
this coming out next year for sure yeah
well I mean you know this can always
happen but they're saying no this 2019
Wow yeah it's been a development for I
think at least two to three years
Leonard Boyarsky was at blizzard before
doing Diablo 3 and he was pulled not off
of that but you know pulled for a
blizzard to rejoin this team and you
know to him this is a dream project
I asked what that means and it's sort of
just like you know him and Tim Kaine and
been working together forever they're
very very different people apparently I
got a sense of that talking to them but
they started work in concert with one
another and offer different strengths
and you know going back to Tim having
notes for every Fallout game and etc
like this game represents a lot of ideas
so they tell me that they've been
holding on to you for a long time and
now they get the chance to realize it so
I hope it works out it looks really
interesting yeah as someone who
personally has not gotten into fallout
76 I know it's an easy comparison to
make I don't want to kick it well it's
down but seeing this kind of stuff and
hearing what you're telling me and
knowing is coming from obsidian has me
really relieved but also excited so that
I'm looking forward to that for sure
it's also exciting to see something that
isn't so desolate and grimy and dirty
yeah that's my input
[Music]
[Music]